the One Piece manga finally has answered
one of the biggest and most important
questions of the recent Story by showing
us that jewelry Bonnie is indeed the
daughter of the Revolutionary jinny but
while we finally had that relationship
confirmed now we have way more questions
than we started with because in this
chapter we were told that jinny was
apparently kidnapped and forced to
become the wife of a world Noble so
maybe she was sold by slavers or she was
taken by the government directly but I
mean wow out of all the options that
we've been discussing for Bonnie's
possible father like Kuma or Dragon Oda
chose the darkest possible way that this
backstory could have gone I mean yeah
we've always known that the celestial
dragons can just randomly pick people
and force them to become their wives
like we saw back in chapter 499 but man
I mean seeing it like this in this
flashback and that Bonnie is the child
of this forced marriage is just a whole
different level of messed up if you ask
me so similarly to some of the St ra
Hat's tragic backstories Oda is really
ramping up the tragic meter to a whole
different level here but to make things
even worse for jinny we next see her 2
years later and she has somehow been
struck by a deadly very rare disease now
unfortunately instead of getting help
she is getting kicked out of marijua and
left alone to die which is where we see
her next in one of the most
heartbreaking moments in recent one
piece history because with her dying
breaths jinnie calls up Kuma and tells
him once more that she actually loves
him and man I won't lie and say that I
didn't tear up a little bit when I saw
that I don't think Oda has ever done a
better job of making me so emotionally
invested in two characters in a
flashback before I mean jinny and Kuma's
story is right up there with law and
kazon for me personally they've been
through slavery poverty pain hunger and
years spent together as kids and later
as revolutionaries which makes it even
more tragic when Kuma is eventually able
to identify where jinny is and he
instantly pushes himself there using his
devil fruit but what he finds is
honestly even more tragic that's because
jinny is already dead with a baby Bonnie
in her arms I mean I don't know guys
this one just hit me very hard for some
reason like harder than usual I mean Oda
has built up Kuma as this impossibly
kind and compassionate figure and now
he's had one of the only people who he
truly cared for ripped away it is truly
heartbreaking and just continues to make
me hate the celestial dragons more and
more as if this were possible in this
flashback and sadly I'm kind of
suspecting that we're not quite done yet
what is interesting though is that this
scene seems to confirm Bonnie's age to
be around 10 to 12 years old since this
has happened about 12 years ago which
honestly has crazy implications for the
present story as well but before we move
on from jinny I want to quickly
speculate on who this evil person that
jinny was forced to marry might be that
ended up being Bonnie's father and
actually do have one crazy idea that is
just incredibly twisted if that turns
out to be true now listen to this we
don't get much evidence on who Bonnie's
father is from within this chapter but
let's go back again to chapter 499 now
as you might remember it's the very
first chapter that we ever met at this
world Noble St Charlos in fact the very
first world Noble we ever see and this
entire scene might actually be some sort
of insane foreshadowing if you think
about it because as soon as Charlos is
introduced he kicks an injured man and
then decides to take this random nurse
as his wife this woman by the way was
already engaged to be married which is
kind of similar to the jinny and Kuma
situation but what's most interesting is
what happens next because then Zoro
shows up and nearly causes massive chaos
by cutting down Charlos you know before
Luffy then does that later now
fortunately for for zaro at this point
Bonnie steps in and uses her powers to
get him out of trouble and now over 500
chapters later I'm just sitting here
wondering if Oda intentionally showed us
Bonnie's powers for the very first time
in the exact same chapter where a world
Noble kidnapped a woman to make them
their wife I mean seriously how insane
is it that almost exactly 600 chapters
later were shown the very same thing
happening to Bonnie's own mother and so
as much as it hurts me to say this this
may have been some really twisted
foreshadowing about Bonnie's actual
father because if we take this scene in
chapter 499 as foreshadowing then
wouldn't it make even more sense that
Bonnie's mother was married to Charlos
his father who is St Roswell whom we met
just a few chapters before this scene
and in fact to make even more
Connections in chapter 497 Roswell
killed a slave who also had his own wife
and child which which is kind of a loose
connection to Jin and Bonnie but I'm
just saying that having all of this
occur so close together could have been
hinting at Bonnie's father all along but
if you're not saying you want a little
bit more of concrete evidence then just
look at chapter 98 when we see Bonnie
sneaking into marijua now in this same
scene Kuma is shown being ridden by who
else but Saint Roswell which could all
just be some sort of horribly tragic
joke that jinnie was forced to marry the
man who later rode Kuma around like a
horse I mean if all of this is true then
Oda has gone to a whole different level
of Twisted and dark with this backstory
but even if it's someone else it's still
dark enough let's be real and if Roswell
should turn out to be Bonnie's father
then that actually means that Bonnie is
related to Charlos and kind of is his
half sister which let's be real is just
terrible like awful I don't even want
that thought in my brain however it is
entirely possible that jinny was married
to some other random World Noble that
we've never heard of or if we want to
name some other important Nobles perhaps
someone like I don't know Garling which
would somehow mean that Bonnie and
Shanks would be related I mean we have
the hair color a little bit possibly
either as siblings or as cousins or
taking it even one step further what if
it was even one of the gooce I mean
we've never seen them with children or
wives or anything like that but maybe
that is why Bonnie is just bursting with
tears when fighting s pattern at the end
of chapter 1090 and4 because let's be
real surely these tears that we see in
this panel right here have to mean that
Bonnie is feeling some sort of even
deeper feelings than just pure hatred
for Saturn I mean obviously it is
suggested that Saturn is the one who
ordered Kuma's memories erased but what
if it is more than just that and Saturn
is the one who forced the jinny to marry
him in fact one Theory from worst gen HQ
on Twitter suggests that maybe Saturn
was even the one who caused jinny's
deadly disease in the first place maybe
somehow it was a side effect of demon
Saturn like abilities that made jinny
and Bonnie sick in the first place and
if that were true then if Bonnie is
somehow able to kill Saturn by the end
of this Arc it would certainly be
fitting Justice and honestly while uh
all of this is getting a little bit too
dark for my personal tastes if any of
these options turn out to be true and
oda's not just hiding her real father
somehow then that means that Bonnie
actually does have cesal Dragon blood in
her veins which just makes me incredibly
curious why they would throw her out
with her mother without even trying to
save her I mean jinny technically wasn't
a Celestial Dragon so that makes sense
that they wouldn't care about her dying
but Bonnie being at least half Bloods
going Harry Potter here has to mean
something right like could just play
some role later on in the conflict
between Bonnie and Saturn although
honestly it does seem like the demon
Saturn is showing absolutely like no
hesitation in trying to kill Bonnie so
either he doesn't care about her lineage
or she doesn't actually have Noble blood
in the first place or I guess sat maybe
just doesn't know that she's the
daughter of a Celestial Dragon but that
seems unlikely or to just throw one more
crazy idea out there what if Oda is
still faking us out and Bonnie still
isn't actually jinny's daughter and sure
call me crazy but we've been wrong about
assumptions like this in the past so I'm
not ruling it out just yet in fact I
also still think the Clone option is is
very much still on the table and could
explain how Bonnie is still alive but
more on that in just a moment because
while her father's identity Still
Remains a mystery I'm also highly
interested in figuring out this strange
disease that affected Bonnie and her
mother the disease itself is called
Sapphire scale and it's even rarer than
the emlet disease that you might
remember that wiped out LW entire town
during his flashback and what we do know
about this disease is that when people
who have the disease go out into the Sun
or the Moonlight they entire body starts
to turn blue and their skin becomes
really har like rock or some sort of
tough animal scales now we aren't really
told yet how she got this disease or if
it is contagious but if it is anything
like the Ember Le disease then it might
be caused by something horrible that the
world nobles were doing at that point
because if you remember from Law's
flashback Law's hometown would actually
mine this so-called Amber or for the
government which was actually deadly
poisonous over time and could be passed
down through generations which seems to
also have happened in the case here
since Bonnie also has gotten this
disease and I honestly have no other
idea what could have actually caused it
other than maybe some government
experiments or maybe a side effect of
the goo say's demon powers or something
I mean blue scales do remind me a little
bit of kaido's scales that he has as a
dragon and we do know that Vega Punk
experimented with that but still that
would be too messed up if it was Vega
Punk's fault right so this leaves us
with the question of how did Bonnie live
while her mother ended up dying prettyy
quickly and you might not realize it but
the answer to this question is going to
have huge effect on the rest of Kuma's
and Bonnie's story because we do see in
this chapter that Kuma took care of
Bonnie for quite a long time in order to
protect her from the disease he did keep
her out of the sunlight for years can
you imagine that like literally not
being able to go outside that's actually
I think also a real condition in the
real world that exists and I do know
Kuma would bring her books and
everything and we even finally learned
the heartbreaking origin of his famous
last question if you could travel
anywhere where would you like to go now
though we get some more of the most
wholesome panels in the entire story as
we see a young Bonnie growing up with a
really happy looking Kuma and man while
reading this I mean I just couldn't help
but really wish that Kuma had just said
yes to marry jinny all those years ago
and then they maybe could have just all
happily lived together as a happy family
but I guess it was never meant to be and
uh we wouldn't have gotten the fields
even though we still see these two
spending all of these years together we
just always knew that this was going to
end in some sort of really tragic way
but sadly they couldn't live like this
forever because as a doctor told Kuma
the disease would still kill Bonnie by
the time she was about 10 years old so
how in the world was she actually able
to be cured well one very reasonable
option would be that Kuma actually used
his paw devil fruit to somehow push the
disease out of Bonnie which does sound
crazy but we have been seeing Kuma push
out things like pain memory
anything so it isn't exactly
unreasonable to assume that Kuma could
push out a disease however like we just
saw back in chapter 1097 someone would
have to take in that disease in their
stad which means that Kuma might have
absorbed the disease himself to save
Bonnie now whether he was just strong
enough to survive the disease or it
didn't affect him because of his
Buccaneer blood we aren't really sure
but if you look at this small flashback
back in chapter 1072 it does appear that
Kuma had some ban on his entire body so
I wonder if this could be some sort of
side effect from this Sapphire scale
disease now of course another option for
how Bonnie lived is that Kuma made some
sort of deal with the world Nobles to
save Bonnie and the easiest way for this
to work would be that Kuma basically
sold himself to the world Nobles in
exchange for medicine or possibly even
Bonnie's age devil fruit because I mean
since this disease does seem to be
indeed age related then Bonnie's fruit
would be the perfect one to keep her
from ever growing too old to be killed
although she definitely has aged herself
up past 10 years old which does make me
wonder if that is really true or not and
so maybe all of that does leave open the
option that the real Bonnie did end up
dying and the one that we see right now
here is actually a clone I mean I don't
know honestly I'm still trying to really
wrap my head around all of this but
whatever the case may be Bonnie is alive
right now and she is now confirmed to be
only 12 years old which is just crazy to
think that she's already gone around and
become a famous pirate around the world
while still being basically a child but
maybe her devil fruits powers are also
affecting her brain to match the age of
her physical body who knows and also it
does appear that in the next chapter
we're finally going to see Kuma earning
his title of the Tyrant King of the
sorbet Kingdom because at the end of
this one the corrupt King that the
Freedom Fighters overthrew back in
chapter 1097 is now back to cause
trouble for the kingdom of self and
honestly I thought that he had been
killed already which I wish was true
because now I'm kind of predicting that
someone is probably going to try to take
Bonnie from Kuma and man that's not
going to end well for anyone I can
literally just imagine Kuma destroying
the entire Kingdom to try and save
Bonnie from being captured or on the
other hand maybe the corrupt King takes
everyone on the island hostage and Kuma
is forced to trade himself to set them
all free and I mean it would only make
sense because Kuma has been consistently
sacrificing himself for years to protect
these people so maybe he will take the
last one option that sacrifices himself
and saves everyone else or of course one
more option to consider is that both
Bonnie and Kuma both get taken in by the
world government perhaps Kuma turns
himself in to save the people of the
sorbet Kingdom and then Bonnie comes
along as well and in fact this actually
makes a lot more sense than you might
think right now because we still have
this super unexplained and weird p
Chanel of former Admiral Akainu saying
that he was worried when he learned that
Bonnie escaped and really it doesn't
seem likely to me that he was referring
to when she was a literal baby so there
has to be some other time that she was
actually captured and then managed to
escape from the world Nobles and on top
of that if you look at Bonnie and
kizaru's conversation back from chapter
1092 it does seem like kizaru and Bonnie
have known each other for quite some
time as well like I mean kizaru even
remarks that she's great grown quite a
bit taller which does make me think that
he saw her sometime when she was still a
kid so with all of this I'm really
thinking that Bonnie was with Kuma for
at least the start of when Kuma agreed
to become a government experiment and
then she later managed to escape which
of course would also explain her real
strong hatred of the world Nobles
however one thing that is certain is
that Bonnie and Kuma's backstory is
going right up there with the saddest in
the entire story so far and if you know
one thing about sad backstories it's
that every single straw hat does have
one so if you've been on board with it
kind of like I have been there has never
been a greater opportunity than right
now for Bonnie to actually join the crew
but if you don't want to wait to see how
exactly Bonnie would fit on a crew with
Luffy I figured out how the entire wor
generation would get along with if they
all were on one crew and you can check
that video out right here also before I
let you go here I think we all saw the
message that Oda wasn't actually able to
finish the drawings for this chapter so
let's actually really hope that is doing
okay I mean he does work super hard
every week to bring us this story that
we all love and nothing could be worse
than him overworking himself and ruining
his health I think and personally I
really think it might be time now to
shift one piece to a bi-weekly schedule
where we only have two chapters a month
just so he has time to rest more but
anyways for now Shanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one